SELFOVERNING STATU AS THE
SNEY CORPORATI CONTIES TO
SP LIES ABOUT THE LAW AS
LL.
HEREITH THE REACTIO
OUUMBERED COHOS
KAEIGH McENANY ALONG WH
X NE CONTRIBUTOR DGLAS
MURRAY,AYLEIGH, STARTITH
YOU.
WHIS THERE THISMPERIVE ON
E LEFT TOO --E A TALNGABOUT KI ,
FIT, SECOND, THIRD GRADE,
TALK ABO TRANSGENDER IS HI
ANSEXUITY AT ALL, ESPECIALLBECAR
STUDEN WIT THE WORST REST IN
READING, WTING, MATH, SCIENCE,
AND COMPUTERS W DON'T W
FOCUON THE BASICS?
>> EXACTLY SEAN.
E LEFT HAS A SKBSESSION
TH OUR CHILDRE
JUST TODAY THINK ABOUT THE LAS
HOURS FOR THE WHI HOUSE.
EY WANT TO FCE FACE CLOTH
COVERINGON 2-YEAR-OLDSN
AIRPLANESND FORCE TEACH THEM
ABT SEXUALITY AND GEND
IDLOGY
KINDERGARTEN
AN MYAUGHTER GOES T SCHOOL,
ION'T WANT HER LEARNING ABOU
THOSE THINGS.
COMING HOMND TEACHING, BEI
TAUGHT THINGS TT I THEN HAVE
TOXPLAIN TO HER
AND  ALLHE ISSUES TO CRY A
STREETS.LOODSHED I OURRE ISA WA.
CHILDR LITERALLY DYI ON E
REETSROM CRIME THATS
TALLY OUT OF CTROL ANDRAMPANT.
THERE ISOVID WHERE MOR
AMICANHAVE DIED ON
JOBIDES WATCH THEN
PRESIDT TRUMP.
ERE IS AOT T CRY ABO.
MELY, IF YOU WT TO CRY ABOUT
ON IUE INHISOUNTRY RIGHTNO IHINS
SECRETARY OULDRY ABOUT THE
EXIST, THAT HE BEEN ABORTEDBECAA
HEINOU HEINOUS DECISION IN
THIS COURY TT HAS
EXRMINATED AUT ONE FIFTH OTHE UO
IF YOU WANTO CRY DON'T CRY
ABOUFORCG SEXUALITY O
KINDERRTNE, THAT IS SI.
CRY ABOUT THE 62 LLION
CHILDREN WHO CAN'T EVEN  TO
KINDGARTEN.
>> Sn: YOU KNOW, AS I LOOK
AT THIS BILL, THE STATE OF
FLORIDA REACD, A YOU KNOW,
IT I TROLING THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATIONOULD BREAK DN
IN TRS BAUSE OF A LAW THAT
PROTEC THE PARENTA RIGHTS
DOUGLAS,T MAY SHO SOME
PEOP IN SCHL SYSMS, BUT
ERE ARE MANY PARENTS OUT TRE
AT HAVE VALUES TH ARE VERY
DIFFERENT THANHE SCHOOL A
VERY DIFFERENT THAWHAT A
TEACHER MIGHTE TEACHING THR
KIDS.
WHO HAS THE RHT T INSTILL
VALUES?ARE WE GOINGO HA O KIDS
OVERO THE SCHLS?
TH GETO INSTILL THE VALUES?
ORO PARENTS GET TO INSTILLHE
VALUES?
I VOTE FOR THEAREN.
>> ABSOLUTELY CE ERY TIME.
JEN PSAKI I TNK IJUST MAKG
SURE HER CAREER AT NBC I
ABSOLULY SAFE.
THIS MIXTU OF NTIMENTALITY
AND FE EMOTION IS SOMHING WEKNOS
FROM RACHEL MADW AND OTHERS,
BREAKING DN IN TEARS,
DICULOUS, INSIGNICANT
THIN, AND THIS I RICULOUS
D INSIGNIFICANIT IS RIDICULOU BS
CRYING ABOUTND YOU JT
POINTED O, SEA SOMHING
THAT ISN'TAPPENG.
THE RIDULOUS THING, ON TOP OF
ALL OF THA IS AS  ALL KNOWHERE,A
HAD NOTHING T DOITH
PERSECING GAY PEOPL OR
ANYTHING LIK IT, IT IS AUT
TRYI TO STOP NOT JT THEIMPOSITIX
TO KINRGARERS, BUT STOPPING
THE TEACHG OF AN IDEOLOGY THA
WAS LITERALLY INVENTE ABOUT 18
MONTHS AGO.
I MEAN, TWO YEARS AGO, NOBOD
HAHEARABOUT ANY OF THI
GEER FLUID NONSENS
NODY TKEDBOUT
NONBINARSM.
EVERODY KNEW UNTIL YESTEAY
THAT THEERE TWOEXESND
ME PEOPLE ARE ATTRAED TO
THEIR OWN SEX.
NOWE HE THIS NEW IDEOLOGY
THEISNEYND OTHERS HAVE
DECIDED TO ENFORCE ON ERICAN
100 GENDERS,O IMPORTANT TOUNDERW
MANY GENDERS THE ARE BECAUSE
THEY ARE MAKINIT UPS THEY GO
ALONG.IS INCREDIBLYANGEROUS WHAT
THESE PEOE ARE DOING.
>>ean: MY FAVORE W THE
RST GRADERS BNG TAUGHT --WHEN D,
THEY ARE REALLY JUST GUESSING IF
IT IS A B OR GIRL.
EY ARE TELLING FST-GDERS
THAT.
TA AN EDUCATEDUESS
IT ISOT A GAS.
ANAY, AND NOBOD SUPRTS
DETERMINATIOI'M AIBERRIAN, LIVEN
LIFE BUT LEAVE T KID ALONEAND LE